the echo fin itself in the agenda we
started with an overview about VAD
reserve charge mechanism is goods and we
also had the chance then to step on
about the possibility in the discussion
about reverse charge mechanism on one
side and there was overview that we have
now a good move to step into decision
finding in between the next weeks the
same was done to the item of EEP
applications where we also had another
discussion in which form we can here
close the files and we also well
prepared over the next weeks and we are
preparing a decision for the next
meeting in October on the EMU deepening
we welcomes a commitment to see us a
banking package and to bring forwards of
work on non-performing loans proposals
these are important risk reduction
measures we also feel that there is
enough of political will to fast-track
the work on the backstop for the single
resolution fund and we also have a
mandate from leaders to work on roadmap
for starting the political discussions
on European Deposit Insurance Scheme in
addition we presented other proposals
tabled in a context of the new
multi-annual financial framework namely
is a report reform support program to
provide greater financial and technical
incentives for reforms at national
levels and we also presented invest GU
program which builds on the success of
the younger plan to boost investment in
Europe